all right the president is uh busy
fending off a series of new accusations
from people who used to work for him
this today including his longtime
personal lawyer
michael cohen highly critical his memoir
disloyal
goes on sale tomorrow the book is being
distributed by simon and schuster a
division of viacom
cbs cohen finished the book while
serving a prison sentence for crimes
related to his role in the president's
2016 campaign
paula reid looks at some of the
allegations in it
president trump's former fixer michael
cohen insists
his old boss is a cheat a liar
a fraud a bully a racist a predator
and a con man cbs news obtained an early
copy of cohen's book where he reveals
president trump's admiration for
vladimir putin's ability
to take over an entire nation and run it
like it was his personal company
cohen's behind the scenes account
corroborates accusations previously made
about the president
including hatred and contempt for his
predecessor barack obama
he was an incompetent president that's
all i can say grossly incompetent
cohen says mr trump claimed the former
president got his ivy league degrees
from effing affirmative action
and while ranting about obama president
trump said tell me one country run by a
black person
that isn't an [ __ ] the white house
called cohen a disgraced felon
who has lost all credibility and says
it's unsurprising to see his latest
attempt to profit off of lies
the administration is also trying to
discredit a report by the atlantic
magazine
alleging president trump canceled a
visit to an american cemetery near paris
in 2018
because he reportedly said the cemetery
was filled with losers
it's a disgrace that somebody is allowed
to
write things like that although parts of
the report have been confirmed by
multiple outlets
the president's v.a secretary defended
him i judge a man by his actions and the
actions have been beneficial
for veterans all across this country in
ways that
we have not seen since the end of world
war ii
this week president trump will visit
several key swing states
including north carolina florida
michigan and pennsylvania where he will
visit on friday to mark the anniversary
of 9 11.
a former vice president joe biden will
also be in pennsylvania on friday
but it's unclear if the two men will be
at the memorial at the same time
tony and as we learn from edo keeps
whiteboard 57 days
until the election paula thank you very
much